[Musique]
chalon vous conter l'histoire les
aventures des aventures nous allons vous
conter l'histoire les aventures de
renard
ce look on appelle primo pour est là
dans cet épi
ona men
dans un arbre
je meurs de faim renard ne m'as-tu pas
dit que tu connaissais un autre moyen de
trouver de la nourriture
bien sûr il y as tout près d'ici une
maison qui satisfera nos désirs
elle appartient un paysan qui possède
trois bojan bon je sais comment s'y
introduire et si vous voulez me suivre
je peux vous y conduire cours sur le
veut mais je meurs d'impatience d'être
devancé boerenbond alors partons
[Musique]
mais avant
le
[Musique]
voyez heureux vous allez pouvoir apaiser
votre femme
[Musique]
il faut se hâter en grains on peut nous
surprendre
je suis prêt mais voilà vingt je crois
avoir trop mangé
qu'est ce qui ne va pas vous de cuir
passe au ras vous voulez rire mais je te
dis que je suis coincé
elles ont essayé encore
[Musique]
attendez nous allons essayer un autre
moyen
[Musique]
allons encore un if so we bought gens
au secours
[Musique]
le coup